you've probably heard this song sampled
in hundreds of hip-hop tracks I was
moving them
did you know that bomb bomb by Sister
Nancy is a sample itself
Jamaican dance hall is a genre that
originated in the 1970s and is rooted in
the art of sampling so when sister Nancy
went to the studio in 1982 she was
inspired by Yellowman who created his
own bom bom song around the same time
[Music]
but yellowman's chorus actually
originates in the 1966 song Bom Bom by
the maytals
sister Nancy then completely freestyled
new lyrics over a different beat pulls
from stalik 17 by Ansel Collins
[Music]
so now when you hear a rap song sample
bom bom today you'll know that it's a
sample of a sample of a sample